The subject of hybrid mana has been pretty
front and center recently in EDH discourse,
and I honestly find it a bit tiresome as a
topic. So, this video won’t be about the merits
of the proposed hybrid mana change, not exactly
anyway. If you want a video that covers the meat
of the issue I’ll be linking a Maldhound
video on the subject that I quite liked,
but now that the dust has settled a bit and
the most sharp-edged of hybrid gladiators
have dulled their roll a bit, I want to
talk about the conversation around it,
and what it means for us. I will only be
discussing the hybrid mana change insofar as
is necessary to make a case that the stakes
here are low and that the reaction to the
suggestion has been quite a notable and anomalous
event, because regardless of whether the change
itself ends up happening, this has clearly
been an event in the online EDH community.
For any of you blissfully out of the
loop, a couple weeks back Gavin Verhey
of Wizards of the Coast made a set of
announcements, both in livestream form
and in post form. A lot of it was pretty
reasonable tweaks to the bracket system,
those being some clarification of the language
of the different brackets, and the moving of
a handful of cards off of the gamechanger list.
The more controversial part of the announcement
was the potential future changes part, where
Gavin discussed the potential future banning
of Rhystic Study and Thassa’s Oracle, and the
possible tweak of allowing hybrid symbols to be
considered either of their colors for the sake of
color identity. The conversation that has spawned
forth about hybrid mana has kinda fascinated me
in the past couple weeks, mainly because of how
unexpectedly strong and unexpectedly plentiful
the opinions have been, particularly opinions
from the anti-hybrid mana side. There was an
initial wave of anti-hybrid youtube videos,
and all videos about the subject have seen massive
numbers of comments, with a lot of people making
a heated case for their side in this debate.
This has been fascinating to me because the
hybrid mana change seems like such a low stakes
issue, no matter what side of it you fall on,
but the community response to the suggested
change has felt like what it would be if WotC was
suggesting literally abolishing color identity.
So, I want to dig a bit into why that is,
what caused this, and to start let’s talk about
literally abolishing color identity—kind of. In
an episode of the Magic Mirror podcast released
in March, I gave a sort of devil’s advocate case
for why color identity should be abolished,
and here are a couple key points from that.
1. Magic: the Gathering is a game based around
mana and colors, with card designs existing
around the fact that colors are malleable
and decks can venture between colors at the
cost of deck space and deck consistency.
There are a lot of designs that color
identity renders clunky, awkward, and nonsensical,
and this restricts players who wish to play them.
2. Advocates of color identity will argue
that limitations are good for decks, but color
identity doesn’t achieve this in a way that is
consistent or fair. Somebody can play a five color
commander and avoid this restriction entirely,
whereas somebody who enjoys a specific monocolor
commander that wants extra support from other
colors gets unfairly limited. Commander is also
a casual format about expression where players
can always choose their own limitations if they
want them, and the format imposing limitations
on its own goes against this spirit a bit.
I think these arguments are interesting, and
they make me curious what a world without
color identity would look like. Despite this,
in that podcast I mentioned that I ultimately
don’t support the abolition of color identity at
this point, preferring instead a set of changes
that fix two cases where color identity feels
particularly unintuitive to me, those being cards
whose identity is defined by indicators rather
than symbols, and hybrid mana. This is more or
less still the position I hold this position
eight months later—color identity should stay,
but fixing up these weird side cases would be neat
and probably good for the format in the long term.
You can agree with that or not, and I’m not
here to convince you about it because this
isn’t a video about hybrid mana. Given that, you
may be wondering why I’m even bringing this up,
and that’s because the comments on
that video basically agree with me,
and that’s interesting. In the context of
hearing a devil’s advocate argument against
color identity and then being presented with
these softer changes, people went “oh yeah,
I like color identity but those changes make
sense.” Am I some kind of god of rhetoric,
fooling innocent commander players into supporting
a hybrid mana change by positioning it as the
reasonable centrist position in the color identity
debate? Maybe, but regardless of framing I have
to wonder what other elements contributed
to this shift. The timing? The atmosphere
within the EDH community? The party making
the suggestion? I don’t know the exact split,
but my best guess is that it’s probably a mix of
these things, and I’m going to go through these.
Firstly, the timing. One version of this idea is
that players dislike this change happening amidst
hybrid mana being more heavily printed, both
in recent sets and in the upcoming set Lorwyn
Eclipse. I don’t think this is a major factor,
or I guess I hope it isn’t, because it would be
a very silly thing to be a major factor. Of course
Wizards of the Coast is going to suggest changes
to the commander format at times where it feels
most salient based on what is currently being
printed, in fact it’d be a lot weirder if they
made a hybrid mana change during a period where
very little hybrid mana was getting printed.
Just so I don’t leave it unsaid, this is a minor
change and isn’t going to meaningfully increase
sales of Lorwyn Eclipse, and WotC knows that. No,
the bigger factor here is what has happened in
the recent past. We just came out of a summer that
saw a lot of dissatisfaction from the community,
with the Spiderman set being both an aesthetically
jarring Universes Beyond set and a poor quality
set in its own right. This was paired with an
announcement that next year will feature four
different standard legal Universes Beyond sets,
out of a dizzying total of seven sets. I don’t
think I have the same emotional reaction to
this as a lot of people, but it’s certainly a
bummer—I don’t like the Spiderman set, and I
don’t like being overwhelmed with endless standard
legal Universes Beyond sets. All of this to say,
there has been a lot to be frustrated about, and
the online magic community has been hotboxing
anger and resentment in all of its various spaces
and subspaces and niches for the past several
months. With the Spiderman set being past us,
that anger has been looking for a new target to
explode out at, and, this month that something
ended up being a suggested hybrid mana change.
This timing factor pairs with the Who of
the announcement. The fact that it was
Wizards of the Coast making an announcement
suggesting this change rather than a handsome
and big-brained youtuber talking about
it in a podcast definitely had an effect,
because Wizards of the Coast is in a rough
spot with community trust right now. I don’t
know who exactly to pin the blame on for every
decision, but the collective decisionmaking
power at Wizards of the Coast and its parent
company Hasbro has been making a lot of pretty
shortsighted choices, and choices that they
know will bother the playerbase. This is not to
say that it’s been all bad for EDH—the bracket
system rollout has gone pretty smoothly IMHO,
and the general quality of products aimed at the
Commander format has been pretty decent lately.
But, that’s arguably part of the problem—the
commander format has been identified as a cash
cow, and a whole lot of decisions about
what gets printed, when it gets printed,
and how it gets printed seem to be motivated by
milking that cash cow. So, it’s in this context
that suggestion of a decision that could be made
about the commander format garners a massive wave
of backlash, getting lumped in with all the other
decisions that have been made in recent years.
So, is this a defense of the hybrid-hating
playerbase? On some level it absolutely is,
in the sense that I think much of the current
climate that produced this is directly due to
decisions made by WotC and/or Hasbro. But, are
people justified in being this angry about the
change? I would say no. A lot of the arguments
against hybrid mana are reheated versions
of the arguments defending color identity I’ve
heard—limitations are good, homogenization is bad,
designer intent doesn’t matter, commander format
architect intentions do matter, and so on. As
arguments in favor of color identity, these are
certainly valid, though a mixed bag in terms of
how persuasive I find them personally. Dredged up
and put into this new context though, they look
very strange because the stakes are so much lower.
It’s like rhetorical homeopathy—the angle you’re
arguing is very minor, almost inconsequential,
and when you argue it with the passion of somebody
whose mother just got insulted, it makes you
look like a goofball. Like take the question,
“does hybrid mana weaken color identity?”
My answer would be only a tiny bit at most,
particularly if Wizards of the Coast is more
careful with the hybrid color pie in the future,
which I kinda assume they will be for reasons I’m
throwing on screen but will not pause to elaborate
on. Then that tiny bit needs to get sifted through
the secondary question of how much does color
identity erosion harm the commander format. Even
if you think the erosion of color identity is
pretty harmful to Commander, which is a reasonable
thing to believe, you need to remember that you
are not talking about the abolition of color
identity, you’re talking about a niche change
to a very specific set of cards that already have
valid arguments to exist within the current logic
of color identity. I think a lot of players forget
that and just pretend they’re arguing against the
abolishing of color identity, and the result is
that conversations end up feeling deeply strange.
Or, take the idea that an expansion of hybrid
mana will allow for the printing of more
widely available broken stuff in the future. The
video from Tomer over at MTGGoldfish is the best
articulation of this argument that I’ve seen, and
there is a small part of me that worries what’ll
happen when we get a Captain America’s Wrath next
year in hybrid red white that’s broken and $120
and desired by every red or white deck. That could
happen, but to contextualize how problematic that
is, let’s go through the steps of that argument.
First of all, how problematic is it if broadly
available, powerful cards are printed? Well, it’s
something that has more or less always happened
throughout Magic: the Gathering’s history, but we
can say that it’s less than ideal in the case of
something like The One Ring that is colorless and
also hits other formats. Step two of this point
is how much does hybrid mana actually impact this?
And the answer is that I don’t see a whole lot of
evidence that this change will lead to a surge in
that. Wizards of the Coast already has colorless
cards that they can use to give a power card to
any commander deck, so the best tool for this is
already available. In addition, if we look at the
current hybrid mana cards affected by this change,
none are staples in their two color identities—the
top two are Cold-Eyed Selkie and Saheeli, Sublime
Artificer, not exactly terrifying must-plays.
Will Wizards of the Coast start rubbing their
hands together evilly and send hybrid Stock Up
or Beast Whisperer to the printers the second
the hybrid change happens? Maybe, but probably
not. One again, this is rhetorical homeopathy—the
risks in this particular case just aren’t
that high, and players are using mental
stand-ins to make their arguments rather
than discussing the reality of the situation.
To be clear, it’s entirely fair for people
to be against the hybrid mana change for
either of these two reasons, the direction
of the disagreement makes sense to me. But
the scale of the disagreement looks
rather strange, which is why I think
other factors I laid out earlier are fueling
the heat of this discussion rather than the
change itself. I don’t think this change is very
high-stakes for the two reasons I just laid out,
and even as Wizards of the Coast has been making
decisions dislike, I also really don’t buy most
versions of slippery slope arguments that claim
this is just the beginning, two little waves
over the top of the conceptual dam that is color
identity. Phyrexian Mana isn’t going to get this
treatment because it’s already been identified
by both WotC and the community as a design
outlier. Off-color ability cards aren’t going
to get added because it’d be simply too large
a change and would require other format changes
to even remotely make sense. And, full-fledged
color identity abolition definitely isn’t going
to happen when even an abolition-curious player
like myself knows it’s a bad idea. I also
think it’s important to remember that this
change wasn’t invented by Wizards of the Coast
two seconds ago. This is something that players
and designers alike have suggested and made cases
for in the past, including myself several months
ago. Not everything needs to be some nefarious
machination by a corporation, and to pretend that
a hybrid mana change is a brand new thing asked
for by no players is just plainly dishonest.
At the end of the day, I still understand why
people tar the decision makers at Wizards of
the Coast as greedy and corporate and nefarious
and other such pejoratives. It seems like this
year has really been an inflection point around
Universes Beyond due to it suddenly making up
a large portion of standard sets. The result is
that even many players who were relatively neutral
about it in previous years such as myself
have started to sour on it pretty heavily,
and the people who were already against it
are finding themselves wading into deeper
and deeper levels of dissatisfaction. The
current trajectory of the game is not a
good one, and though I’d reject the doomerism
that communities of internet-enjoyers tend
to cultivate, there is reason to be unhappy.
That said, I also hope we as a playerbase can
get better at calibrating the temperature
of our discussions. When we respond with
disproportionate levels of anger and gloom to
lower-stakes suggestions, I worry that it weakens
our ability to be taken seriously on the things
that matter more, and also distracts from those
more important things. There are real decisions
being made that have the potential to seriously
impact the future trajectory of the game, and
the impacts of the hybrid mana suggestion are
microscopic compared to the addition of even a
single extra standard-legal Universes Beyond set.
I also think it’s better for the health of
the community to not blow every announcement
and update way out of proportion. When I see
comments declaring every tiny thing as the
death of the game, it makes me think of the vast
array of spaces across the internet where people
marinate in collective despair and pull themselves
deeper and deeper into conspiracy and doomerism.
It’s not that much of a problem just yet, but
that’s just something I’ve been getting little
whiffs of this year, and it’s not healthy. Maybe
it’s because I’ve been involved in a wide range
of game communities, from flourishing to actively
dying, but my general reaction to a game company
doing stuff I dislike is to either distance
myself from it, or to take some control into
my own hands. The first is absolutely helpful
sometimes, and I fully believe there are people
discontentedly sticking around with Magic
who probably need to move on to other things,
but I’m going to focus on the second. If
what Wizards of the Coast is handing you
doesn’t satisfy your needs, build something
for yourself—a format, a subformat, a cube,
a community, a different game, or just a playgroup
of people looking for the same sort of fun as you
are. The best antidote to feeling disempowered
and dissatisfied by the decisions of others is
to take back control of your own enjoyment.
That’s undoubtedly harder than just accepting
what a game company has to offer you, but the
potential benefits are well-worth the effort.
Thanks for watching! And thanks to
Archidekt for supporting the channel.
I’ve been working to finish my fall supporter
deck review, and it makes life so much easier
when I can port somebody’s deck into Archidekt,
do all the necessary categorization and analysis
to get an idea of what’s going on, and then
have the in-website categories look nice
enough for me to be happy just throwing them
in a video as a visual. I’ve also been brewing
a couple new decks lately, and if you want to
check those out, a link to my decks is in the
description. I also want to thank my patrons
for their ongoing support of what I do here.
I had some stuff to say about the nature of
“design intent” that didn’t feel quite at
home in this video, so I threw them in their
own separate video for supporters. If that’s
something you want to hear me talk about, you
can become a YouTube member or Patron today.